Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Du tissu aérien.
C’est beau, n’est-ce pas ?
Vous connaissiez avant aujourd’hui ?
Qui, dans la salle, avait déjà assisté
à une représentation ?
Vous ? Vous ? Vous êtes nombreux !
OK.
Eh bien, moi, je suis littéralement
tombée dedans.
Ou plutôt, je me suis accrochée.
J'ai eu la chance de me trouver
au bon moment, au bon endroit.
C'était vers la fin des années 80.
J'étais en fac.
Une étudiante plutôt rebelle, engagée,
cherchant à donner du sens à sa vie.
Un jour, au détour d'un amphi,
je tombe sur un flyer.
Atelier cirque.
Et moi qui n’y connaissais
absolument rien dans la discipline,
me voilà attirée comme un aimant.
Je vais découvrir une passion,
ce qui va nourrir ma vie
jusqu’à aujourd’hui.
Un an plus tard, je rentre au Centre
national des arts du cirque
de Châlons-en-Champagne.
Le Graal.
Là, un monde s’ouvre à moi.
L’effervescence artistique
d’une école jeune, peu connue,
où tout est à construire.
Une page blanche.
C’est grandiose.
Je vais ainsi participer
à la naissance de la discipline,
élève déterminée, audacieuse.
La vie devant moi.
Pionnière dans l’exploration encore
vierge d’une longue verticale.
Un diplôme des métiers des arts en poche,
je débute ma carrière qui est
à la hauteur de mes ambitions.
Je vais côtoyer toutes les disciplines
artistiques, du théâtre à la danse,
en passant par la musique,
les arts de la rue,
les arts plastiques, le cirque bien sûr,
mais aussi le cabaret et le monde
jusque-là insoupçonné de l’événementiel,
des soirées privées,
des clubs, de la nuit.
Trois exemples d’expériences
que j’aimerais partager avec vous.
Mes débuts avec la célèbre
Compagnie des Arceaux.
Un premier voyage en Australie.
Je découvre le monde,
je suis jeune, fougueuse,
amoureuse de la vie.
La scène est une passion.
J’aime créer, jouer, me mettre
au service de nouveaux projets.
Le plateau ? Une addiction.
Le sens de ma vie au présent.
Un jour, une agence événementielle
me propose une expérience unique :
participer à l’inauguration de la nouvelle
boutique Louis Vuitton à Bangkok.
Waouh !
Voyage en première, conditions de rêve,
le luxe s’ouvre à moi.
À Bangkok, je me suis fait faire
ma robe de mariée sur mesure.
Enfin,
je suis invitée à chorégraphier
pour un festival de musique sacrée
à la basilique de l'Épine.
Une personne du public dira
que les saltimbanques doivent rester
sur le parvis des églises.
Un prêtre écrira :
«Fred priait-elle ? C’est son secret.»
Polémique.
J'ai enseigné et chorégraphié les tissus
aériens pour de nombreux artistes
talentueux au travers le monde.
En 2020, j’ouvre à Saint-Nazaire un lieu
culturel qui porte le nom de la Volière.
un clin d’œil
à tous ces oiseaux sortis du nid.
Que représente pour moi
cette longue verticale ?
La danse aérienne m’offre la richesse
d’une autre spatialité
en défiant les lois de la gravité
pour pénétrer dans le domaine du sensible
et ainsi sculpter l’air.
Source d’inspiration infinie,
j’imagine ce tissu comme le symbole
de la colonne vertébrale
qui me fait tenir debout.
Un axe qui me relie les pieds
sur terre, la tête en l’air,
le corps en suspension,
cherchant continuellement à me dépasser
et à trouver des espaces de liberté
entre forces de jaillissement
et relâchement.
J’explore les matières,
intéressée par l’idée que le vêtement
est une prolongation de l’individu.
Tissu enveloppant,
telle une deuxième peau,
une enveloppe charnelle.
Cocon protecteur et fécond.
Je danse une danse universelle
entre ciel et terre.
Ce mouvement permanent de la vie
que nous connaissons tous,
chacun sur le chemin de sa quête
personnelle d’identité,
d’authenticité, de spiritualité.
Ma philosophie de vie.